تسببت المقاتلات الشبحية في
إحداث ضجة كبيرة
بين أمريكا وحلفائها في
الإمارات العربية المتحدة
، حيث أوقف الإماراتيون المحادثات بشأن
شراء طائرات بقيمة 23 مليار دولار
بسبب فرضنا
قيود تشغيلية سيادية وتفاصيل فنية أخرى
يبدو أنها تشمل الولايات المتحدة  في محاولة
للتأكد من أن طائرات F-35 التي
وافقوا بالفعل على بيعها لإسرائيل لا تزال
تتمتع بميزة على تلك التي قد يبيعونها في
مكان آخر
أه أردنا التأكد على سبيل المثال من
أن التزامنا بالتفوق
العسكري النوعي لإسرائيل مضمون لذلك
نحن  أردت التأكد من أنه يمكننا إجراء
مراجعة كاملة لأي تقنيات
يتم بيعها أو نقلها إلى
شركاء آخرين في المنطقة
بما في ذلك الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، فقد قام الإماراتيون
بإعادة ضبط سياستهم الخارجية
بعيدًا عن
التدخلات العسكرية التي تنتقد كثيرًا في أماكن مثل
اليمن وليبيا.  ربما لم يعودوا
بحاجة إلى مقاتلين متخفيين
بعد إخلاء الحلفاء لكابول
وسنوات من الفوضى في العراق.
هم حليفهم الأكثر أهمية
ولكنهم غير موثوق بهم حديثًا ،
إنهم مستاءون أيضًا من
المحاولات الأمريكية لإيقاف شركة هواوي الصينية العملاقة للتكنولوجيا عن
تزويد شبكة 5G الخاصة بهم ،
ونحن نطالب بأن يغلق الإماراتيون
عملية بحرية صينية هنا ، وأعتقد
أن الشيء المهم أيضًا
هو المحاولة
و  هذا حقًا فقط
للقوى العظمى للقيام بمحاولة إدارة
صراعها
وإدارة منافستها
بطريقة لا تنزلق حقًا
إلى حرب باردة ثانية والتي أعتقد أنها
ستكون كارثية
لكلا العاصمتين وكذلك للجميع
ارتفعت التجارة مع الصين بنسبة 40 في
المائة تقريبًا بالنسبة للإمارات هذا العام
، والآن بعد أن
ابتعد الإماراتيون عن الانضمام إلينا بقيادة
مغامرات عسكرية في المنطقة ،
أصبحوا في مكان أفضل لتجارة الخيول
في سوق الأسلحة
الذي أعلنوا عنه مؤخرًا.  19 مليار
صفقة دفاعية مع فرنسا
وشمل ذلك 80 مقاتلة رافال
، وبينما عرضت الولايات المتحدة نموذجًا بالحجم الطبيعي لطائرة من
طراز F-35 في أحدث معرض جوي في دبي ،
سرق هذا العرض
وصنعه
في روسيا
سام كيلي سي إن إن أبو ظبي
[موسيقى]
أنت